josée legault michel david hâlé
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir je sois alors
la nouvelle est tombée et docteur arruda
l'a confirmé lors du point de presse de
13 heures une femme de 54 ans de la
montérégie en pleine forme apparemment
qui après avoir reçu une dose
astrazeneca est décédé vendredi au
plusieurs dents ça s'agite pour
plusieurs il ya 400 mais je vous montre
le tableau il ya quatre cent mille
personnes et plus je sors québec consul
astrazeneca l'argent inévitablement ça
augmente le degré d'inquiétude mais tout
ce qu'on va les écouter avant de vous
donner la parole entre le monsieur
legault et monsieur dubé ont dit le
risque même si tragique vaut la peine on
y connait on ne vaccine et le 400 mille
personnes astrazeneca
ces quatre cent mille personnes qui ont
beaucoup moins de risques de travers de
retraite perco vide et hospitalisé peu
d'entraînement décédé donc dans balance
des inconvénients je continue à penser
que c'est un risque calculé
mais évidemment quand on pense à cette
femme de sa famille ses proches d'abord
geof toutes mes sympathies ips et ses 2
vous bien comprendre que là il ya un
risque est toujours eu un risque mais on
le dit le ce risque là de deux des fers
collatéraux sont moins de un pour cent
mille qu'on regarde tous les bénéfices
de la vaccination regarder le nombre de
deux décès qui est en baisse le nombre
d'hospitalisations comment qu'on ne plus
contrôler en hausse et hsd grâce à la
vaccination je pense que l'adéquation il
est facile à faire mais malheureusement
ça arrive de ces colloques je pense que
les gens vont continuer d'aller se faire
vacciner alors josée legault
on le savait je me répète mais c'est une
chose de savoir si une autre chose que
d'imaginer cette femme vendredi alors
c'est sûr que c'est un choc quand même
je vous hais oui tout à fait je peux
comprendre d'un point de vue
scientifique là toutes les explications
les rationalisations mais c'est sûr que
c'est un décès c'est une personne qui on
nous dit qu'ils étaient en pleine forme
ça fait partie des risques
personnellement je ne me prononcerai pas
sur la question des vaccins vraiment pas
mon expertise mais c'est clair que
lorsqu'on regarde ce qui s'est passé en
grande bretagne par exemple on utilise
énormément
il ya quand même ça a contribué aussi à
la baisse de la propagation d
hospitalisation etc
cela étant dit c'est clair que c'est
pour chaque personne et tout
particulièrement les farmer qui sont
peut-être plus sujettes à cet effet
possible la de réfléchir de prendre une
décision décision éclairée mais c'est
une décision que le personnel mais c'est
certain que la nouvelle d'aujourd'hui ne
va pas nécessairement aidé la réputation
d'un vaccin qui a tort ou à raison était
déjà
on savait qu'il y avait un risque bien
sûr c'est triste d'ailleurs on voit que
le l'évaluation et à bonn 400000 de
doses qui ont été injectés et il ya
quatre victimes a fait cas personnes qui
ont subi des travaux dont une est
décidée alors on est on est vraiment
dans les chiffres qui était prévisible
maintenant je me souviens qu'au départ
on avait dit qu'on réservistes ce vaccin
et l'eau 65 ans et plus madame qui est
décédé à 54 ans alors évidemment la
question s'il est évident que s'ils
avaient tous reçu le vaccin ne serait
pas décédé mais il reste que je présume
que le risque augmente avec la jeunesse
avec l'âge auquel on le reçoit
alors est ce que là on est rendu aux 45
ans et plus au canada ses 30 ans et plus
je m'agite qu'il ya des gens qui ont
moins de 55 ans par exemple
moins de 40 ans qui vont y penser à deux
fois avant d'y aller
oui ça c'est ce que le gouvernement ne
veut pas en fait avec que ça refroidisse
des gens qui doutent mais ça peut
arriver à court terme en tout cas je les
ai trouvés quand même c'est secouer le
trio 100 t il par rapport à ce qu'aulas
probablement parce que ça les touche
directement les statistiques c'est une
chose d'avoir les informations sur
quelqu'un qui concrètement subi les
conséquences de la vaccination
c'en est une autre et je pense qu'ils
ont aussi une pointe d'inquiétude sur la
suite des choses
comment les gens vont recevoir cette
nouvelle là il y avait un engouement
très manifeste pour l'astra zeneca dans
les derniers jours là certainement qui
en a qui vont y penser à deux fois
oui les bénéfices sont bien plus grands
que les risques vous avez beaucoup de
risques de subir une thrombose si vous
attrapez la cobi 19 bien plus grandes
comme risque que si vous avez le vaccin
mais il ya quand même des gens qui vont
se poser la question là en terme de
communication politique communication
publique
comment on veut raffiner le message est
que ça va être suffisant il faudrait y
penser là parce que certainement qui est
ça pourrait ça pourrait influer sur la
suite des choses et pas le vaccin qu'on
reçoit en plus grande quantité mais
c'est quand même un vaccin qui était
important dans l'arsenal du gouvernement
du québec
c'est un défi d'autant qu'aujourd'hui on
essayait de convaincre certaines
clientèles d'y aller bon bien si vous
venez pas cette semaine ont peut-être
qu'on va ouvrir à tous le monde michel
davy je relance avec vous peut-être
qu'on va ouvrir à tout le monde plutôt
prévu la vaccination
oui bah écoutez la vaccination je passe
de façon générale va très bien
je sais pas si ça dépasse les prévisions
qu'il avait faites mais on voit le les
chiffres le québec est le deuxième je
pense après la saskatchewan à rassasier
votre bien maintenant à écouter les
plages sont ouvertes pour les gens
le ces catégories là s'il ne se présente
pas pour toutes sortes de raisons il y
en a qui peuvent sans doute est
excellente
il me semble dans l'ordre des choses
qu'on procède avec qu'on élargisse je
veux pas et tant pis pour les gens qui
seront pas aller mais on peut pas
attendre non plus que tout le monde l'a
avoir l'assurance que tout le monde soit
vacciné avant de procéder et élargir en
quelques manches jose s'est simplifié
aussi le l'interface de communication le
ciel vous j'allais réaliser
oui mais pour moi ce sont deux choses
séparées au gt gt tony dans ses
commentaires lors au point de presse
qu'est ce que les personnes entre autres
les personnes déficientes
intellectuelles reprocher des handicapés
qui qui n'avait pas pris beaucoup de
rendez vous mais la date qui avait été
communiquée c'était à partir du 28 avril
pour la prise de rendez vous donc demain
il humanise la santé a annoncé hier
après midi que ce serait si matin ben
c'est pas tout le monde au québec et sur
twitter et qui suit le minus bersauter
là dans les organismes communautaires et
dans les milieux des personnes
handicapées la date c'était le 28 et
elle a été répétée sur beaucoup beaucoup
de réseaux donc moi j'attendrais un
petit peu et je dirais aussi que ya déjà
un certain nombre de personnes
handicapées qui ont été vaccinées soit
dans les ressources intermédiaires sas
avait été un arrêté ministériel au mois
d'avril on en avait parlé ici à londres
patrice et et d'autres qui vivent dans
leur famille où il ya plusieurs familles
qui n'ont plus ce système d1 et qui ont
été vaccinés de manière tout à fait en
respectant les règles mais qui ont fait
appel à leurs promesses sociales alors
clsc etc et l'austère bifrare d'étoilés
savez je suis sympa donc très désiré
plus d'argent j'aurais pu d'abord le
français ça fait trois quatre jours que
je veux parler de sujets puis
l'actualité nous a à faire
nous a forcés à faire autrement je vous
fait entendre un petit extrait de
monsieur legault c'est à jeudi où il
parle de la clause nonobstant pas pour
la loi 21 mai pour la langue de ce
projet qu'on attend on écoute on vous
comptez vous utiliser justement la
clause dérogatoire pour renforcer le
projet de loi pourrait sur la charte de
la langue française comme madame anglais
justement est prête à le faire mais on
l'exclût sûrement pause mais je pose
couper notre annonce donc mais faut
sûrement pas exclu mais vous allez le
voir quand on va déposer le projet doit
exclure ces rebelles
ça veut dire qu'on peut l'utiliser que
des bonnes chances qu'on utilise
on attend je le rappelle on en a
beaucoup parlé à ce panel le projet de
loi ou le le bouquet de mesures que nous
promet le ministre jaulin bared michel
davy nous avions un texte intéressant
dans le devoir supporters vous dites est
ce que par exemple ça pourrait pas être
le retour de l'affichage uniquement en
français et là on aurait besoin de la
clause dérogatoire pour ça est ce que
vous pensez qu'il jongle avec ça ce que
ça pourrait être une des mesures qui
pourraient définir monsieur legault
honnêtement je le souhaiterais mai
je ne m'attends pas à ça mais quand
monsieur legault a déclaré ce qu'on
attend du temps à tous je me suis tout
de suite posé la question parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont prévisibles
dans le projet de loi que monsieur je
l'aimerais doit déposer mais des choses
qui n'exige pas en principe une clause
nonobstant ces si on plafonne le nombre
d'admissions dans les cégeps anglais par
exemple je pense pas qu'on ait peur que
ça soit renversé par les tribunaux même
chose pour la langue de travail étant la
francisation aux entreprises le de 26 à
49 ans fut envoyée je pense pas non plus
que ce soit un code de se présenter
devant un tribunal pas plus que par
exemple mettra en vigueur le latic de
noah qui a jamais été finalement amusant
dia qui forcerait le gouvernement à
s'adresser en français à aux entreprises
ou aux migrants alors qu'est-ce qui
rennes un obstacle tout fait on passe à
l'affichage c'est la seule fois où ça a
été utilisé dans une loi linguistique
l'a88 c'était la loi 178 précisément
pour maintenir la règle de
l'unilinguisme français dans l'affichage
commercial qui avait été invalidée par
la cour suprême alors est-ce que c'est
ce à quoi pense monsieur legault
peut-être mais je ne sais pas je m'y
attends pas d'air mais non mais
maintenant c'est intéressant ce chef
vous poser la bonne question si c'est
pas ça qu'est ce qui requiert la clause
dérogatoire dans le dossier de la langue
parce que josée legault on à monsieur
legault le laissait entendre un club
sourire
regardez vous allez voir attendait soyez
patients mais c'est pas impossible qu'on
l'utilisent
oui mais ce n'est pas garanti non plus
c'est que on est face à une boîte à
surprises ça on ne sait pas ce qui va y
avoir dans ce bouquet de mesures costaud
de promise par le ministre si mon chat
les barrettes pour renforcer la loi 101
et très franchement on parle de très
loin moi je documente les reculs la
langue française depuis 25 ans donc je
ça fait longtemps qu'on a des problèmes
donc on part des très très loin moi
aussi je serais étonné qu'on touche à
l'affichage commercial par contre
parce qu'il ya tellement d'autres
urgences donc on essaie poste ce qui
semble décès qui semble plus difficile à
comprendre c'est le temps que ça prend
plein et là et tiraillements qu'elle est
très long conseil des ministres ce que
le premier ministre dit sur un certain
nombre de choses mais moi j'ai pris la
déclaration de monsieur legault comme et
à bombay s'il faut on l'utilisera
l'homme et à moi qui ai pris goût avec
je sais pas mais mais on essaie vraiment
pas à quoi s'attendre
bon qu'est ce qui achoppe les questions
gay pourquoi c'est si long pourquoi
c'est si long avant de présenter bon la
sphère des cégeps ce jeu des barrettes
en conférence de presse a dit oui on
songe à sa d'appliquer la loi semble sur
le goût une heure après 1,1 au salon
bleu avait dit non là on sait plus on
pourrait plafonner plus tôt où vous en
êtes dans votre analyse de ce bouquet
qui n'arrive pas d'abord au gouvernement
on est convaincu que présenter quelque
chose d'aussi important alors qu on a
par exemple une deuxième vague en
janvier où une troisième vague qui se
font et s était pas une bonne idée qui
fait débat de société qui se devait se
faire avec un peu plus de sérénité qu'on
attendait donc nakheel me si elle se
produit quelque part en mai et en juin
on devrait y arriver avant la fin de la
session
il ya aussi des gens gouvernement qui
trouve que c'est pas une mauvaise idée
de retarder le projet de loi sur la
langue parce que si on veut en faire un
arsenal politique pour la campagne
électorale puis ce sera proche de la
campagne mieux ce sera ça sera plus
frais dans les esprits
on aura le débat autour de ça il ya une
autre possibilité qu'on n'a pas abordé
moi je pense que françois legault avec
un sourire comme celui-là s'apprêtent
elles utiliser la clause nonobstant je
vois pas un premier ministre qui se fait
un beau sourire comme ça hop ne se
laisse pas impressionner
moi je les perçois qui évolutif ni
l'état ni faire quoi
mais il ya une autre option il ya
l'option de l'utiliser sans
véritablement en avoir besoin
parce que d'un point et de poing d'un
point de vue nationalistes de pouvoir
dire ce loup alors peu importe par où on
va la prendre et inattaquable france est
important la loi 21 7 est clair que la
lettre il va invalider par les tribunaux
on en avait besoin et ce qu'on à 9
un besoin pour la langue j'ai hâte de
voir les détails si c'est l'affichage
c'est vrai michel deux raisons il y en a
besoin mais ce que pour le reste ils
vont vouloir la blinde et un peu comme
rené lévesque le faisait à une certaine
époque où l'un des tous ces projets de
loi la clause nonobstant en protestation
avec la rapatriement de la constitution
est ce qu'on vous ne l'utilisez pour
pouvoir dire le france est important
puis on va l'utiliser même si en réalité
on est pas sûr qu on aurait vraiment
besoin il ya toujours cette possibilité
là aussi qu'elle soit dans dans cette
loi pour qu'il ya une possible oui j'ai
peut-être pour ce qui est du cégep à
partir du moment où on plafonne les
places est ce qu'on va dire
la priorité sera accordée aux
anglophones de souche par exemple ou
d'autres et ce qui sous-entend qu'il ya
des francophones qui pourrait ne pas y
avoir accès même s'il demandait et qui
pourrait peut-être s'adresser aux
tribunaux pour dire je suis victime de
discrimination en fonction de la langue
peut-être que c'est ça alors on a de
voir la proposition de monsieur jolie
barrette qui nous disait cette antenne a
pas si longtemps oui c'est vrai prêtre
mais il ya d'autres considérations qui
sont ajoutés ont sans doute évidemment
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne soirée
à très bientôt avoir voir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit